this weekend for our edition of the dish
we want to take a step back and focus on
the restaurant workers who have been
among the hardest hit by the pandemic
crisis in the first wave of 700,000 job
losses in March 60% were bar and
restaurant employees and that same month
the National Restaurant Association
estimated that a three month shutdown
could mean the loss of up to seven
million jobs but there are some bright
spots amid the devastation creative ways
and creative chefs and owners are
keeping their workers on the payroll
while benefiting our communities once
rated best restaurant in the world
eleven madison parts dining room now
sits idle I miss my team usually there's
250 people working in this restaurant
kovat 19 has moved the action into the
kitchen we're just a handful of chef
Daniel Holmes employees prepare meals
that won't cost diners a dime so
essentially you've turned this Michelin
star restaurant into a soup kitchen a
community kitchen you know if for like a
million dollars we can produce 200,000
meals and create a hundred jobs his
former sous-chef Mack Josie I helped him
do it he runs the nonprofit rethink food
rethink originally started as an
organization that collected excess food
and then redistributed it to local
nonprofits with an assist from American
Express Eleven Madison Park expanded
that reach some 30 other eateries will
be turned into distribution centers
we're feeding about two two to three
thousand people every day before Corona
and now we're feeding anywhere between
five and seven thousand people a day and
at the end of this month we hope to be
feeding over 10,000 people a day
nationwide the industry is laid off more
than three million workers up to a
hundred billion dollars in revenue could
be lost by the end of this month across
the country some have found ways to feed
that need Emeril's in New Orleans
Nightbird in San Francisco Lucille's in
Houston not simply by lifting spirits on
social media but by keeping payroll
afloat lessons chef Kris Williams
learned from hurricane Harvey their
biggest concern is that providing its
face for our staff to be able to
continue to provide for their families
had to take profitability completely out
of the equation williams discounted
prices by 30 percent and dedicated
proceeds from his food and bottled ready
to go cocktails to his team his new
curbside pickup and delivery model
allowed for 75% of his workers to remain
on the job as opposed to utilizing all
these apps which we do use some of them
we wanted to drive our clientele to
utilize to allow us to deliver for them
we know what the cost of doing
businesses lights rent gas goods and
then the people that it takes to make
all that stuff bring it all together
what surprised you we figured the best
that we would do would be $3,000 a week
gratefully enough we've been able to do
more like eight times that I think we
have the most beautiful curbside pickup
in the whole state in Lexington Kentucky
chef ouita Michel always fed the city's
hungry now she's established an
emergency relief fund for its newly
unemployed while she laid off a hundred
and sixty one of her 200 employees she
kept them on health insurance and
provides three meals a week and gift
cards from a local supermarket there's a
part of me that just wants to only it's
hard to be in business right now and
there's so many people who are and I'm
so grateful to be able to do it in
Harlem chef JJ Johnson's field trip
takes its name to heart focusing on
schoolchildren they haven't had hot
meals in two weeks so I'm going to start
a feeding shelter a week about 200 bowls
and partner with Harlem grown I'm gonna
make sure the dailies get one hot meal
for this week Johnson is also feeding
hospital workers
attitude has turned many spaces like
Brooklyn's Olmstead into life lines
[Music]
chef/owner greg Backstrom partnered with
makers heart
Brooklyn's hometown barbecue and his
distributors to turn his storefront into
a food bank we're able to feed you know
several hundred of people a day with no
end in sight you notice the people
coming to get the food they look
familiar that part is pretty impacted
like you get to a place where you're
seeing a couple of people that used to
work for you thanks to a GoFundMe page
and loyal customers he's also raise
$75,000 for his crew while raising his
voice for neighborhood businesses who
need more government assistance I am
using every freaking Network that I can
possibly have to have conversations with
the former chef of the Obamas - the Tom
Colicchio's and use that platform to
influence our legislators to just help
the people that are literally living
around us helping each other one side
effect chef Daniel whom hopes will
define the industry on the other side of
this pandemic why do we only produce
these meals today in such a crisis why
haven't reproduced meals for people in
need much more frequent before my hope
is that we will learn from this and I
think hunger in this country can end
it's an emotional subject for them it is
an emotional time for them some of them
are quite angry though they're angry
over the fact that you know they can
survive but it's the little mom-and-pop
restaurants who can't so they're
speaking up for them because they don't
have the same voice they're making sure
that they're their words and their their
their emotions are being felt and
obviously Michelle it's going on across
the country at so many places I think
what Daniel Humes
whom said there in the end this idea
that can we carry this forward we have
to keep helping each other we've talked
about it throughout the show it's
something that maybe we all can learn
from